The Texas governor is
vowing to pardon a convicted murderer
before he has even been sentenced.
This case is exposing
the conflict
between two bedrock principles
of the modern Republican Party.
Namely this one
we support the right of every law abiding
American to be able to have a weapon.
And also this one
we have
God given rights.
And included in those God
given rights
is the right to self-defense.
To bring you up to speed,
Garrett Foster was killed
as he was legally protesting
the death of George Floyd in 2020.
At the time,
Foster was legally carrying an AK 47.
Daniel Perry's attorneys
presented a case for self-defense
at the trial.
Last Friday,
a jury found him guilty of murder.
The sentencing date for him
has not even been set yet.
But already, Texas
Governor Greg
Abbott has tweeted his intention
to pardon Perry.
In Texas,
the governor can only grant a pardon
after the board of Pardons
and Paroles makes a recommendation.
Abbott has requested
an expedited review of this case.
I want to note
that we invited the governor
on this show tonight
or this week to join us.
Now, we are speaking
to the district attorney
in this case, Jose Garza, who joins us.
And thank you so much for being here.
The idea that this sentencing date
has not even been set
yet and already
the governor is moving ahead with this.
What's your reaction to that?
Well, Caitlin, my first
thought is about the foster family,
about Garrett's parents and his fiancee.
They waited
so long to have their moment in court.
They waited so long for justice
for their son.
And justice,
I think, feels
so elusive to them right now.
But I want them to know
that the Travis County district
attorney's office
is going to continue to fight
for a criminal justice system
where everyone is treated
equally, including Garrett Foster.
Have you spoken to the family yet?
I have had the opportunity to visit
with the family on multiple occasions.
I had the opportunity to visit with them
today.
I won't speak for them.
I think they will
have their opportunity to speak
very soon.
But I can only tell you
that they're heartbroken right now.
Okay, good to know
that you've spoken to them.
If this pardon goes through,
I think an important part to note
is that the board's members
here are appointed by the governor.
He's saying he'll bring it.
If it comes to his desk, he'll sign it.
If this pardon does happen,
do you think it undermines your office?
Well, simply by making this announcement,
the governor has undermined
the rule of law in the state of Texas.
And he has made our community less safe.
Every single day here in Travis County,
we hold people accountable
who commit acts of gun violence.
We are going to continue
to hold people accountable
who commit acts of gun violence.
And obviously,
if the governor wants to continue
to pardon
people who commit acts of gun violence,
that's up to him.
But there is no doubt in my mind
that it makes our community less safe.
I want to show a moment of something
that was said on Fox
News in the hours
before We heard
from the governor's office
about what he intended to do.
This is what happened
This is a legal atrocity.
It's so obviously unjust that
we extended an invitation
to the sitting governor of Texas,
Greg Abbott,
to come on this show on Monday.
And we wanted to ask
if he was considering a pardon
for Daniel Perry.
But for some reason,
Governor Greg Abbott's
office told us he just can't make it
and that we should
talk to the attorney general
of Texas, Ken Paxton, instead.
So that is Greg Abbott's position.
There is no right of self-defense
in Texas.
Do you think criticism like that
played a role in the decision
that Governor Abbott has made here?
Well, you know, Caitlin,
what makes our criminal justice
system just is people.
It is the fact that in our democracy,
it is the people who have the final word
through their service
on grand juries, through their service
on juries.
And what the governor has said today,
what he said over the weekend,
is that those people don't matter.
And it is deeply troubling
that someone like Tucker
Carlson may have more power
in the state of Texas
than the people
who live here and serve in our community.
District Attorney
Jose Garza will wait for that
sentencing date to be set,
see what happens there.
Thank you for your time tonight.
Thank you, Audie.
You know
the district attorney,
you've spoken with him before.
I wonder what you make of the position
that they're in
and the idea
that legal experts are saying
if this pardon goes forward,
it does erode the justice system
in Texas.
It's not just
that Garza is one of a handful
of so-called
progressive prosecutor leaders
who had the support of protesters
in the Black Lives Matter movement.
And so he is very much kind of a part
of having a more kind
of progressive approach to public safety.
And what's happening with
Abbott is a clash of
of the politics here. Right.
The backlash to the BLM movement
is coming in the form of Abbott
and others.
There was a wave
of anti-protest legislation
that came out of 20, 20 and 2021,
including in the state of Iowa,
where they actually created
a civil shield law for people who
harmed a protester in a protest.
So there is kind of a movement of people
who say
get these guys out the streets,
get these bums out the streets,
we don't want to see this protest.
And Abbott is kind of playing
to that crowd
with the potential for this pardon.
And that means people like Josie Garza,
who I've talked to about this,
are facing serious political headwinds
for the sort of progressive movement
they believe themselves to be a part of.
What do you make of it?
I mean, given
what Abbott is
saying, is his defense about the Stand
Your Ground laws in Texas
and the that side of this,
why not let the sentencing play out
It just seems to undermine
the deliberations of 12 jurors
who spent a long time
they spent several hours
deliberating on a unanimous
verdict there.
But it really
at the heart of this for context,
if you go back to
there was a guy
named Harlon Carter
who was living on the border
in Texas back in the fifties.
There was some racial tension
with Mexicans in nearby.
He ended up
murdering a 15 year old boy
with a shotgun, was convicted of murder,
but then released from jail
two years early
because the judge didn't
explain to the jury
the proper definition of self-defense.
At that time.
Harlan Carter
went on to be the head of the NRA.
At the time,
they pivoted from a club
that was for marksmanship
into a political wing
that gave their first endorsement
after 100 years
to Ronald Reagan in 1980 and now that's
180 million guns ago in this country.
The political force of that decision
who took the NRA in a place
to fortify for a race war
instead of a civic
gun safety
organization was a key moment in history
and I think you're
seeing that play out now.
This is like canonizing
the Kyle Rittenhouse's of the world.
How have you feel about what went down
to undermine just
the basics
sense of a jury trial at this moment
and to choose sides
in a gunfight
based on who is protesting what?
Boy, that's dangerous
and it feels like
and it's important to remember
what was introduced at
the trial were his messages
that were posted that day.
One saying, you know,
I might have to kill a few people
on my way to work.
They're writing outside
my apartment complex.
I might go to Dallas to shoot looters.
These are the words that prosecutors
used against him in this trial.
Yeah, but I mean, there's
so many absurd things about this.
One of them to me there really jumps out
is that Abbott's
point is that the Stand
Your Ground laws in Texas are so strong,
which I feel like undercuts his logic.
Yes, they're so strong.
And the dude still got convicted.
And I am a Texan,
and I'm here to tell you,
we're really understanding
when you shoot somebody,
we will give you
every benefit of the doubt
that maybe you had a reason to do this.
And will people still unanimously said,
no, this isn't enough.
So with the strength of those laws,
the person still got convicted.
That's a huge part that really throws me.
You know,
when we see how this all went down.
But I think we're already
saying it is very important.
The idea that you can shoot somebody
just because they're protesting
seems to be something
that they want to go.
But there's also, again,
to get into the irony of this,
the man who got shot
was carrying
an AK 47,
and the idea was that
the shooter was scared of him, thereby
he shot him.
First of all, the idea that I'm scared,
therefore I can shoot it
so that legally
we really got to find a way
to get to the bottom of it
because being scared
isn't a good enough reason
to shoot somebody.
But if the AK 47 means by definition
it is scary to somebody
and then they can shoot you.
It would then raise the question
about whether you should be able
to have the AK 47.
But we're not going to do that either
because again, Texas
so it all comes again
this jumble that doesn't make any sense.
It feels very much like
being watched
Tucker Carlson or somebody
watching and gave him a call and said,
Hey, Tucker, talking about you.
Oh, well,
I guess we need to at least act like
we're going to do something about this.
So all of this is done.
And I guess for larger, like national
type stuff, because in Texas,
the right
of Texans to shoot
people will never, ever
be infringed upon.
Period.
Well,
and we've seen how even Governor
Abbott has changed the gun laws
since all of this happened.
We'll see what happens
when that sentencing date does come down.